apple's new macbook pros have taken the
world by storm earning various world's
best trophies for everything from the
world's best laptop speakers and
displays all the way to the world's
fastest laptop cpu performance and even
beating out the fastest rtx 3080 mobile
graphics performance in certain
workflows and if you follow this channel
you might already know that i fully
believe that apple created the best
laptop in the world if you consider the
entire package not to mention the insane
battery life and the class-leading
resale value and because of all of that
i predicted that apple would spark a
laptop revolution with windows laptop
makers caving in and switching to
arm-based chips to get the best
combination of performance and battery
life just like these new macbook pros
but then on the morning of october 23rd
an article was shared on twitter
claiming that cpu performs benchmarks
for a new intel alder lake laptop chip
had been leaked apparently outperforming
apple's m1 max which was obviously hard
to believe but then i opened the link to
find that it was actually true intel's
new i9 12900 hk chip pulled ahead of the
m1 max by almost 500 points in the
multi-core test while being almost 50
faster than intel's previous flagship
chip and even faster than the previous
desktop flagship the i9 11 900k which is
absolutely mind-blowing and based on
that i think we can safely say that
intel came back with a bang with their
new 12-gen chips almost making it seem
like they've been holding back for
months for the perfect opportunity to
strike and steal apple's thunder so that
right there is exactly what i'm gonna
discuss in this video including whether
i think intel has created the m1 max
killer or if it's just a fluke that
won't end up materializing when these
laptops start showing up in the real
world and then i'm also going to talk
about if intel can actually compete in
terms of other factors like performance
per watt and battery life as well as the
most important thing of all real
performance and productivity workloads
but before i get into all of this alder
lake talk i want to give you guys some
context about how big of a deal this
comeback really is but first i want to
mention that only around 27 of you guys
are subscribed so if you haven't already
do so right now to help us reach your
goal of a million subs before the end of
the year or you could support us by
checking out our new notchbookpro merch
design in the merch shelf right below
this video thank you now since i was
already expecting apple to create the
world's fastest laptop chip i made a
video four months back discussing how
intel's x86 architecture would
eventually die off to make way for
arm-based chips starting with laptops
first but then i made an updated video
two months back discussing how intel is
gonna come back with a vengeance and
that was based on two different points
the first point was that at the time
intel was rumored to be buying out sci-5
the maker of high performance risk 5
chips that are very similar to arm-based
chips and they were even making plans to
start pumping out these new chips for
laptop use as soon as next year and the
second point was that their x86 based
alder lake was actually looking very
promising and they could help power
intel through this tough phase before
switching to those risk 5 chips for
laptops but just two days before those
leaked benchmarks showed up on the
internet it was reported that intel's
talks with sci-5 about buying out the
company have suddenly ended without a
deal which means no more risk five chips
for intel so here's what i think
happened i think intel began testing
their new 12th gen laptop chips only to
be completely blown away by the almost
50 percent multi-core cpu performance
jump compared to the previous flagship
channel and at that point they realized
that they struck gold and they no longer
have to resort to paying millions of
dollars to develop new risk 5 based
chips so they basically called the deal
off and potentially released those
benchmarks themselves just two days
later as a warning shot to apple and amd
and to be completely honest if these
leaked benchmarks turn out to be true
what intel has achieved has totally
blown me away and at this point in the
story i can finally admit that x86 isn't
dead and if intel continues to keep this
up then x86 ain't going nowhere anytime
soon so with that said i started doing
some research on how intel was able to
pull this off including what potential
downsides these chips could have
compared to apple's m1 max chip
and ultimately what all of this means
for real-world performance so without
further ado let's get into the
technicals as you might already know the
secret sauce to alderlake is the use of
a big little cores which is essentially
a mixture of powerful cores and
efficiency cores which is something that
apple has been using ever since the a10
fusion chip in the iphone 7. now the
main benefit of this is that previously
all of the cores would essentially have
to be identical making it easier for pc
software to schedule processing tasks
but the problem is that intel would have
to find the perfect balance between
performance heat output and battery life
which is why we have that tdp rating
based on what device the chip is going
into but now with big little technology
intel can make their performance course
even faster to further improve single
core performance without sacrificing
battery life because you've also got the
low power efficiency cores that can
handle simple tasks on their own
drastically reducing power usage and
improving battery life but then when
firing up all of the cores together
using intel's new thread director
technology that is now supported in
windows 11 you also get incredibly
impressive multi-core performance like
we saw in those leaked benchmarks which
were likely also pushed further by
intel's more efficient 10 nanometer
process which is finally ready for
mainstream but with that said don't
think that intel just swooped in and
obliterated apple's new m1 max ship
because there are still some pieces to
this puzzle that we've gotta talk about
with the first one being power draw
oozman persada who wrote the article
revealing these groundbreaking leaked
benchmarks also mentioned that this new
chip is using roughly the same tdp as
the previous gen i9 11980 hk processor
and according to jared's tech on youtube
the maximum wattage that the 1180 hk hit
was a massive 93.7 watts within the
gigabyte aero 17yd which keep in mind is
a bulky 17-inch laptop that measures
21.4 millimeters thick which is about 27
thicker than apple's m1 max 16 inch
macbook pro which we were only able to
get up to a peak of 31.3 watts which is
quite literally three times less peak
power than what the new intel chip is
supposed to peak at so if we convert
those leaked benchmarks into performance
per watt metrics the m1 max takes the
clear win showing just how much more
efficient it really is now if you're
wondering about sustained wattage
hardware unboxed tested the 11980 hk and
it ran at a sustained 75 watts of power
while inside the even thicker 25.9
millimeter msi g76 raider laptop
compared to our testing of the m1 max
running at a sustained 28 watts so
performance per watt improves a little
bit for the intel chip but then we
actually got some incredibly impressive
leaked cinebench r23 benchmark numbers
for the lower end alder lake i7
12700h scoring as much as 18 500 points
in a single run of the multi-core test
but then going down to 17 203 points for
a full 10 minute stress test so if we
compare that to the 10 minute score on
the m1 pro chip the intel chip is about
37
faster which is extremely impressive
basically proving that multiple alder
lake chips are going to be outperforming
the 10 core m1 pro and max by a huge
margin now the only weird thing is that
some of the other leaked benchmarks
don't really make sense like for example
the 12700h only scored up to around 11
000 points in geekbench 5 which is quite
a bit lower than the m1 pro and max and
then in a separate leak the 12 800h
somehow scored even lower than the 12
700h which doesn't really make any sense
but one thing we know for sure is that
the tdp is rated at 45 watts so we can
try to figure out the performance per
watt now in our office right now we also
have a 45 watt tdp 11 900 h inside of
the pretty thin razer blade advanced 15
laptop and it peaked all the way up to
103.76 watts before going down to a
sustained 65 watts throughout a 10
minute cinebench r23 run so if we assume
that the new alder lake 45 watt 12700h
will run at a similar sustained wattage
we end up with 265 points per watt
compared to 449 on the m1 pro giving it
70 percent better performance per watt
so what this ultimately means is that
apple is still gonna remain the
efficiency king because the alder lake
intel laptops will obviously use much
more power and they'll likely also down
clock drastically when you unplug the
power adapter from the laptop which
might explain the vastly lower
6400 leaked geekbench 5 score on the top
of the line 12 900 hk chip however intel
actually has a pretty awesome trick up
their sleeve to improve battery life for
future raptor lake chips which are
coming after alder lake it's basically a
new digital linear voltage regulator
power delivery system which could reduce
power by up to 25
which is huge and should help with
battery life but when you dig into
intel's official patent application you
can see that there is absolutely no
advantage at all when above a certain
amperage which a twitter user estimated
to be over 50 cpu load so this is really
only going to help for more common
simple tasks not productivity work but
nevertheless setting aside battery life
and efficiency there is no denying that
intel's new higher end alder lake laptop
chips will be able to outperform apple's
m1 pro and max by a pretty big margin
basically proving that x86 isn't going
anywhere anytime soon so i've got to
give props to intel for doing such a
great job with their alder lake chips
now the only question that remains is
real world performance in real
productivity workloads because as we've
already seen apple's unified memory
architecture is incredibly impressive
leading to mind-blowing programming
performance like compiling mozilla
firefox almost as fast as the new best
of the best alder lake 12900k desktop
chat and the only way to figure out the
true real world performance is to
actually test it out so if you want to
see us compare the new m1 max chip to
the older lake laptop chips click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one and definitely
check out one of those two right over
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]